[موسيقى]
افغانستان بلد تحكمه حركه طالبان بقوه
السلاح وحكم يقول لا مكان للنساء قيد
صارمه ابعدت النساء والفتيات عن الحياه
العامه
وحرمتهن من حقوقهن الاساسيه احدها الحق في
التعليم الا ان الافغانيات دافعنا عنه
بسلاح المدارس السريه في كل صباح باحد
افقر احياء العاصمه كابل تجتمع فتيات في
منزل للدراسه هو جزء من شبكه من ثمان
مدارس في خمس مدن تقدم خدماتها سرا
وبالمجان تدعمها منظمه افغانيات تعمل في
المناطق الشديده التاثر بحظر مدارس البنات
على الحكم في افغانستان عام 2021 الا ان
هناك ما يقرب من 250 امراه تاثرنا بحذر
طالبان للتعليم في التسعينات هنا انفسهن
بنتنا يبحثنا عنهم مجددا في المدارس
السريه رغم الخطر الذي يواجه المعلمات
والطالبات الا انهن يتمس بالتعليم
المتحديات احتمال التعرض للاعتقال والقتل
ويتحايلنا على اعين عناصر الحركه باخفاء
ادوات التعليم وسلك طرق طويله ومختلفه
نتركوك كتبنا في المنزل وفي الفصل اذا كان
لدينا واجب منزلي نكتبه على قطعه من الورق
بقلمنا ونضعه في جيبنا
العائق الوحيد امام المدارس السريه ليس
سهلا اذ ان سريتها ثاني عدم حصول الطالبات
على شهادات رسميه وتدق ناقوسم خوف ظهور
جيل من الفتيات عشنا حاضرا وسط الحرب
والقمع
وبانتظارهن مستقبل رائع روان حمزه العربيه
[موسيقى]